[Applause]
[Music]
Bolivia has recently undergone a
whirlwind of events elections electoral
fraud civil revolution and finally
something that seemed impossible the
fall of Evo Morales we're gonna tell you
the story of how Evo Morales went from
having all of the power to giving up the
presidency and even being on the run and
then caught so listen up
on October 20th 2019 general elections
were held in the country after night
after the results were announced social
piece exploded since then the protests
and demonstrations of both the
opposition and the supporters of the
ruling party Evo Morales's supporters
occurred relentlessly in the country's
main cities and what some call the
Bolivian Spring the La Paz Airport
turned into a battlefield a City Hall
devoured by flames and teargas shot at
the innumerable blocking points
installed throughout the country the
situation was so tense that was even a
police reliance police riot against Evo
Morales who denounced as a coup d'etat
the first rebel was the tactical unit of
police operations in the central city of
Cochabamba and shortly after other
city's commandos rioted all this is
related to something we already
predicted here on visual politic we told
you how Evo Morales had fallen in love
with power how it ignored the current
law in order to run for president
again and how everything indicated that
it stop at nothing to stay in power
even if that meant following the rule
boy for strategy that has kept
characters like nicolas maduro
Daniel Ortega Rock Juan Orlando
Hernandez and power power and any price
well that's exactly what happens but
having said that let's see exactly how
events unfolded in Bolivia
[Music]
a foretold story
this whole story began on February the
21st 2016 Vandy 51% of Bolivians
rejected the modification of article 168
of the Constitution in a referendum this
constitution which clearly prohibits the
re-election of an individual for more
than one term of office was approved at
Evo Morales's own request the President
and vice-presidents term of office is
five years and he or she may only be
reelected once continuously article 168
of the Bolivian Constitution faced with
this situation with a constitution that
you yourself approved and that is so
clearly laid out and having lost a
referendum to modify it you'd probably
say okay I respect the rules and other
candidates should probably run for my
party at least that's what happens you
know in a country with a sort of minimal
respect for the rule of law
well Evo wouldn't leave power no way
[Music]
and as in every country where the
government has power over all the
institutions it didn't aim to work the
public good
but for the good of the government
itself
[Music]
thus in 2017 the plura national Bolivian
Constitutional Court published grotesque
0:08 4 / 2017 a judgments by which
articles of the Constitution itself were
declared unconstitutional which included
article 168 therefore allowing for
indefinite re-elections how well yeah
let's just say welcome to Evo Morales's
Bolivia the fact is the Constitutional
Court's controversial decision was a
huge blow to Bolivia's rule of law in
the end it didn't matter what the
Constitution sand or what the Bolivians
themselves voted for the only thing that
mattered was what Evo Morales wanted and
faced with this situation large numbers
of Bolivian society took to the streets
to protest under the cry of Bolivia said
no but here's another question do you
think this affected even Morales at all
did it make him rethink his position or
try to reach an understanding with most
of Bolivia society who had voted against
his re-election well no obviously not
Evo made it clear that all he wants is
power at any cost
[Music]
but things did stop changing at that
time the government had played fair and
they lost the referendum so they made
sure that when the time came they
wouldn't lose at the polls again and do
you know what it was a done deal
from that moment strange abnormal bun
heard of situations began to happen
check it out
[Music]
many members and officials of the
Supreme Electoral Tribunal resigned due
to the government's very strong pressure
there had been a very suspicious
electoral roll increase of a hundred and
ninety percent between 2005 in 2019 a
spectacular growth that evidently
doesn't match population growth for the
same period of time and things got even
worse as the elections approaching the
Pueblo is taking a Stannis is tap EDM
location respected guests a tribunal
supremo electoral renews it what can you
not respect other than to know FA not
any most confianza cannot respect added
turning party mas that movement towards
socialism didn't hesitate to use state
resources to campaign and of course the
electoral authorities said nothing
against it meanwhile these same
authorities were busy censoring
independent surveys that didn't declare
Evo Morales a winner for example that
happened with the surveys prepared by
the higher university of san andreas but
just a second why would the government
census surveys well just think about it
for a moment if you're going to commit
fraud you want to make sure it's not
huge scandal Asst right
[Music]
although that the only company
authorized to perform the quick vote
counts on election day it was VN ciencia
a company that's less than a year old
that sounds like a good idea giving
control of a large and complex electoral
process to a newly created an
inexperienced company right are there
you have it the road towards electoral
fraud was nicely paved so you want to
know exactly how even Moralez stole the
elections well listen up the great heist
[Music]
the Supreme Electoral Tribunal Bolivia's
highest electoral authority promised to
deliver 100% of the quick count results
by 8 o'clock on election night well you
know what happens when the time came the
Electoral Tribunal delivered 83 percent
of the count results not all of them and
the electoral results broadcast was
suspended without any notice or any
clarification by that time the
preliminary results marked clear trends
Evo Morales was winning in the first
round with forty five point two eight
percent over Carlos Mesa the main
opposition candidate who'd obtained
thirty eight point one six percent
therefore there was only a seven point
one two percent difference between the
two candidates which according to
Article 167 of the Constitution would
lead to a second round
[Music]
Oh what do you sell you know there's a
little moon come on face more then you
see article 167 of the Bolivian
Constitution states that the candidate
who gets 50% of the votes would be
declared presidents alternatively if a
candidate gets more than 40% of the vote
with ten points ahead of the candidate
with the second-highest votes he or she
can also be declared presidents if these
conditions aren't met a second round
must be held a second rounds in which
given the results victory wasn't quite
so certain very very Alice however we've
already told you that Evo wasn't willing
to lose power and what's more he had a
plan the following day and after more
than seventeen hours of unexplained
suspended coverage a fast preliminary
results transmission jumps from
eighty-three percent to ninety five
percent only to be suspended again until
finally five five days later a hundred
percent of the official vote count was
reached
and surprise surprise the results were
suddenly very different there was to be
no second rounds because Evo had beat
his rival by more than 10 points ends
well that's when everything kicked off
thousands and thousands of citizens
began to amass in front of the Electoral
Tribunal and suspicion of fraud ran wild
no survey no Paul nor any statistical
program had foreseen such a vote
deviation a deviation at the ends of the
counter that was completely opaque ins
happens amid serious irregularities in
the counting process
[Music]
- Peggy's mama presented but Roberto
this is what led to protests throughout
the country protests that fundamentally
demanded one thing clean elections as
you can imagine the government's first
reaction was to try and stifle the
protests through repression using the
state security forces and while that was
that far from seeking a solution to the
problem what Evo did was denounce an
alleged coup against him against him a
president who didn't hesitate to ignore
his own constitution and deploy all
state institutions to his personal
service
[Music]
okay so some of you might now be
thinking well okay Simon but I mean
really was the fraud the electoral
robbery was it really so blatant well to
be quite frank yes
practically all the independent players
agree on this for example international
organizations that acted as observers
during the elections such as the
European Union or the Organization of
American States have recommended holding
a second round because the official
results just can't be accepted every
election must be governed by the
principles of certainty legality
transparency fairness independence and
impartiality the mission was able to
verify that several of these principles
have been violated through different
paths throughout this electoral process
report from the Organization of American
States observers and that's not all even
civil society members spotted a lot of
irregularities for example there's the
case of computer systems engineer Edgar
Villa Grasse who along with the team of
professionals has worked on comparing
the official calculation tables with the
results transmission his conclusion was
that the process was full of traps which
included the elimination of voting
results tables to favor
mas Evo Morales party and there's more
check this out Bolivia the official
audit described the elections as quote
null and void and Carlos Mesa demanded
new elections the company hired by the
Supreme Electoral Tribunal delivered a
report stating that it cannot quote
attest to the integrity the results end
quote of the presidential elections held
last 20th of October as you can see not
even the companies that the Electoral
Tribunal itself hired which has a fully
backed Evo in the past dares to validate
the results the fraud is just too
evidence
and finally the Organization of American
States observers preliminary report was
very much in the same vein fraud deceit
scams and mockery of the public will all
of this was evidence Evo Morales wanted
to become leader just like his friends
nicolas maduro and Daniel Ortega who as
you all know are experts in ignoring the
democratic process anyone who's been
following Bolivia's political news knows
one thing Evo Morales was going to stay
in power no matter what however the
street protesters didn't want to see Evo
become a new Nicolas Maduro and the
bumbling and scandalous way in which he
tried to perpetrate electoral robbery
meant his shot backfired the police
began to mutiny so they wouldn't have to
comply with the government's repression
orders and that along with the mass
protests that were taking place in the
country bed Evo to announce a call for
new elections convoke era
hawawa selección a tsunade's kami dante
el voto permit ran away laureano and
here they were prácticamente
as well as authorities but was the same
person who committed the fraud going to
organize and stand for election again
what credibility with that process have
mili repeating the elections is no
longer enough the people on the streets
the opposition parties the independent
media all the forces outside mas had
begun demanding the president's
resignation and finally the army
followed suit
[Music]
go get them recorded until we get the
line in fact that was the last straw
without the people without the police
without the army even Morales was forced
to hand in his resignation and resign
from Bolivia's presidency Bolivia's
Morales resigns amid scathing election
report rising protests but just a second
because the drama doesn't end there this
is what followed Evo Morales travels to
Mexico on a plane owned by the Lopez
Obrador government and so that's how Eva
Morales is time in Bolivia came to an
end after his departure the new
transition government has announced a
call for new elections elections that
will be supervised by international
organizations now fine the procedure may
not have been the best but Bolivian
democracy was at stake Evo would have
had to leave but he got drunk with power
and decided to turn Bolivia into his own
personal playgrounds of course it
doesn't in there Olivia now faces not
only a deep institutional conflicts but
also significant economic imbalances
Evos most recent years were really bad
and the future is far from clear the
country needs a complete change of
course we're gonna talk about that in an
upcoming video so now it's your turn do
you think Evos departure will be good
for bolivia well leave your answer in
the comments below as well as in this
survey and I really hope you enjoyed
this video please do hit that like
button if you did and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos also
please do check out our friends at the
reconsider Media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode the mine and
as always I'll see you in the next video
no Polly Libra Nepali Lonnie